let's get right back to the phones at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go to our caller
from the 7 1 8 area code caller from 7 1
8 what's your name where are you calling
from
hey JD what's up the capacity of the
u.s. in your opinion to provide the
opportunities for a healthy safe and
prosperous life in the years ahead
substantially diminished co-stars cop 2
I asked is a well-traveled person and a
first-generation American and a person
of color who works remotely in IT
currently and I'm prepared to i'ma grade
out of America after travellish
restrictions are lifted separately
speaking to relatives who work in health
care in New York and DC areas yeah I
figured out the worst of the sores cough
- pandemic here in the u.s. is ahead of
us not behind us hopefully you can see
some of my fears and frustrations but
thank you for everything you do David
well listen I mean here's the deal JD
the the pandemic itself at some point is
going to pass and there's going to be
irreparable health harm that is done -
what what could be hundreds of thousands
of people that died we don't really know
what the death toll will be but it seems
like you know within a month it could be
over a hundred thousand and then who
knows how high it's going to go in the
US eventually we're going to get past it
and the economy will start to recover
but what we've learned from this is that
even an economy that looks pretty solid
and I talked about this on yesterday's
program is pretty fragile right like
it's pretty damn fragile I mean the
stock market was near record highs
unemployment near record lows we had
consumer confidence was was relatively
high inflation under control etc etc and
eight in eight weeks we've lost 21
percent of the workforce 21 percent of
the workforce has lost their jobs there
are people without health insurance
there are people who are in Food lines
so I don't know that the pandemic will
actually change the reality of this
fragile economy but the pandemic has
exposed how fragile even a seemingly
good economy can be and that is some
thing that I'm guessing people are going
to remember the rest of their lives
thank you David
all right appreciate the call thank you
so much let's go next to our caller from
the seven five seven area code
who's calling today from 757 hello yeah
that's you
hey David this is a heir from Virginia
Aaron oh cool Aaron let me just mention
so we're having this issue with the
phone system where when people talk loud
it actually creates a paper crunching
noise and I can't control that on my end
so maybe just put the phone like a
couple inches further from your face and
then I think you'll come in beautifully
that is so much better thank you all
right I'm bring this article on
Washington Post about trumpet stalling
this Republican donor to the Postmaster
General position yes and I really I just
have two questions one is is there any
argument that Trump had that maybe
Amazon isn't paying enough for the
delivery and I coorporate the paying
enough delivery there even an argument
about there there's an argument that so
let me address that Amazon makes deals
with multiple carriers so I'm not an
expert on shipping and logistics but
from what I understand Amazon I believe
Amazon in the US only uses ups I don't
think they do FedEx although I may be
wrong but my understanding is that in
the US Amazon cuts a deal with ups where
they are not literally paying for every
package the way you or I might if we
send a few packages a month my
understanding is that it's a combination
of fixed fee deals plus some other
amounts so Amazon and other large
shippers have always struck deals with
shippers where if you only look at the
per package price it might seem like
it's a loss but you need to look at the
value of the total contract so my point
is I don't know that what Trump is
saying tells us the whole picture but I
would need to investigate it more okay
just the fact having this Republican
appointee the position to control people
voting by
that out this 2010 election yeah seems
pretty scary uh um do anything about
this yeah
Trump so Trump fires inspectors general
who are going to look into things that
he doesn't want looked into Trump
bullies departments into getting rid of
people that are opposed to what Donald
Trump wants to do so unfortunately this
is a situation we're between a rock and
a hard place because the only solution
is to remove Trump in November and yet
Donald Trump is taking steps like
appointing a friendly Postmaster General
who may be able to assist in not having
vote-by-mail work so one way would be
it's going to be up to States to decide
about vote-by-mail you could have a
state say hey we're gonna do vote by
mail and then the Postmaster General can
generate a paper which says hey you know
what the post office would not be able
to properly handle all of Florida voting
by mail and they can create all of this
fear uncertainty and doubt to put in
question whether we're gonna do it so
unfortunately our only solution is to
remove Trump and Trump is actually
putting people in power who may hamper
our ability to do that I don't have an
answer it's dystopian and nightmarish
and you're right to point it out it even
seems like he could just you know gosh
had them blown strike like they shut it
down I don't know what the logistics of
that would be but I would I wouldn't put
anything past Trump to at least attempt
at this point in time and he knows
vote-by-mail would be terrible for him
and he's going to try to prevent it from
happening at least in swing states where
where it could flip the results Wow
pretty good all right appreciate the
call thank you so much